what is an
anti-hero an anti-hero is a character
who has perhaps become
disconnected from the heroic
qualities that audiences might expect of
a
protagonist now an anti-hero to be clear
may be fully in line with their own code
of living they may be very heroic to
themselves but the term
anti-hero is really about the
relationship of the audience to that
hero more so than that person's
relationship with thems at least on a
conscious level now maybe unconsciously
they've got some conflict between who
they are and who they want to
be I have really enjoyed
the recent series The Mandalorian
because it takes a character that is in
many ways a classic
anti-hero especially in the way that
many old classic westerns featured
stories of anti-heroes characters that
maybe didn't fit the mold of of being
the Law and Order person in the west or
the Galaxy but lived by their own code
and yet we see how that code is still
honorable we see qualities of djaren
who's the character in The the suit of
the
Mandalorian um we see qualities of that
character that we say this is an
honorable way to live even
though this character in many ways uh is
is done things and continues to do
things that we might find challenging or
problematic I believe anti-heroes have
become a very popular type of character
for storytellers to work with because
they force us to challenge aspects of
ourselves about what's good what's bad
is is it a binary are there lots of
Shades of Gray in between and perhaps we
can reconcile ourselves because I have
been a good guy but I've also been a bad
guy I've been many things in between so
when we see a character that vacillates
between the the Shadow and the light it
it gives us a certain level of hope that
perhaps we too have value in our
vacillation between the Shadow and the
light the last thing I'll say about an
anti-hero is this
anti-heroes are are characters that
speak to what should be in a story they
are characters that
disrupt the world of a
story and this makes for good
storytelling because anytime the world
is disrupted by a character that story
becomes more profound it becomes more
power ful it becomes stronger so
introducing an anti-hero into a story
can be a powerful way to shake things up
even when that anti-hero is not
necessarily the protagonist of the story
it can still be an effective way to open
up aspects of the story that uh affect
the other characters many times a a a
character um may be the the most
interesting character in the story we
might point to that character uh I think
of The Godfather you know Marlon
Brando's character is not the
protagonist of The Godfather Michael
Corleone is the protagonist of that
story and yet the central character of
The Godfather is a force of nature
character that the effects of that
character rattle out and affect every
other character in the story it doesn't
mean though that that character has to
be the protagonist
how is it possible to love an anti-hero
more than the hero in a story many times
we love the anti-hero more than the hero
in a story because we see ourselves more
clearly in the
anti-hero sometimes we see heroes or
protagonists in stories and we say oh
I'd love to be like that I wish I could
make the decisions that she makes in
this story because she is really living
the type of life that I want to live and
that's
beautiful but many other times we see an
anti-hero an anti-heroine in a story and
we say
ah that character's like me I I know
what it's like to make a poor decision I
know what it's like to be selfish I know
what it's like
to bristle at
Authority many times we see ourselves
more clearly in these characters um
because we're willing to look at those
qualities in characters that we might
not be willing to look at within
ourselves Joseph Campbell once talked
about the fact that it's sometimes the
case that some stories are so important
we can only talk about them through
metaphor we can only express them
through metaphor there's some ideas that
are so uh profound and so um uh
meaningful to us that we have to have a
bit of separation from them in order to
do them Justice in order to really wrap
our heads around it we need a bit of
separation and the anti-hero is a
wonderful way for us to have enough
separation from the things in our own
life and in our own Journey um that uh
that we might be a little hesitant to
actually approach within
ourselves does an evil character have
any good inside of them an evil
character needs to have some good inside
of them in order for them to be
interesting to
us
now there certainly is a place in every
story for flat
characters not every character in a
story can be a character that is going
to go on a heroic Journey or be a
character that's going to uh have layers
and develop and become someone that they
were not at the beginning of the story
sometimes there's a real
place for flat
characters
however if your central antagonist if
the the most evil character in the story
is just purely evil and they're the only
evil force in the story we might get
bored Fair fairly
quickly it is more interesting to us in
my opinion to have at least some Nuance
in a character that allows us to
understand where they're coming from so
in many an antagonistic characters uh we
we talk about what we we say is having a
rational moral argument for that
character in other words we we might not
agree with that character but um we at
least understand a bit of where they're
coming from so um one of my favorite
scenes in any film in the last you know
couple of decades is in the dark night
when we see Batman and the Joker put in
this room together and Heath Ledger's
Joker gives this master class on his
moral rationale of how he and Batman are
are the same and it really causes us to
think about the evil within a character
now the Joker seems to be this
irredeemable character that uh just
wants to watch the world burn that we
hear that phrase said about him in the
story but as we listen to him begin to
explain where he's coming from even
though we don't like it there are
aspects to it that we say ah I at least
relate to that little piece a little bit
I relate to that little piece a little
bit there are
certain types of characters that embody
such evil uh with without being being
able to be redeemed that we we don't
relate to them so we don't see them used
in storytelling very often we do not uh
find any redeeming qualities as an
audience in a character that crosses
that line so that is going to be a
character that's just pure evil and
we're not going to allow ourselves
psychologically to see anything but that
so I think storytellers have to be very
careful in using characters that are
just pure evil because we as an audience
um are going to uh Usher them into one
place in the story and that's where
they're going to have to stay and be and
if that works with your story that's
great but many times um we we're wanting
something that's a bit more fluid and so
it's usually more interesting to have a
character that is not pure evil but that
has some Nuance at least somewhat of a
of a Justified rational moral argument
for what they're trying to
do do evil characters carry more pain
than the rest of
[Music]
us there's an interesting dilemma that I
believe many storytellers find
themselves
in for some
reason many people in our culture feel
like experiences of pain pain are more
profound than experiences of
Joy this causes us to romanticize pain
in a way that can be
unhealthy and it can cause us to create
certain elements of a story that
audiences may have trouble connecting to
um and they don't even know
why but when we see a
character
who is embodying some sort of
evil often times we will see the source
of that evil be an experience of pain
that they had many times in the
backstory of a character we will see ah
this character has become such an evil
person because of something that
happened to them earlier in their life
it's an interesting interesting idea and
I think different storytellers come at
this problem of evil and um how how it's
uh what its relationship with pain is
especially an antagonist uh in different
ways personally I believe that when we
are
children we often will have some sort of
experience that causes us to start
telling a story to ourselves about
ourselves and I believe there's only a
few basic stories one story may be I'm
not good enough something happens where
that child tells thems I'm not good
enough and so they spend the rest of
their life trying to convince everyone
that they're good enough it could be
that that child experiences something
where they believe they're bad no matter
what they do they feel like they're bad
and so they would spend the rest of
their life trying to convince the world
I'm not bad I'm not
bad it could be that that child has an
experience where they feel like they
don't matter and they spend the rest of
Life their life trying to convince the
world that they
matter so when we talk about um you know
the the ways that people grow up and and
become evil um yes they it could be
because of some sort of entitlement you
know that uh that they've taken on but I
personally believe that even entitlement
comes from a place of a story someone's
ends up telling themselves about
themselves and that even entitlement or
some um uh other less than desirable
quality ends up becoming the result of
something that um a child doesn't have
the uh mental capacity it in order to
tell themselves a different story all
the evidence seems to point towards this
and this is the way the world works so I
personally believe it's it's often the
failure of someone uh in in relationship
to that child now I don't necessarily
believe that person that failed the
child is an evil person I think in some
senses um it's the job of every parent
to to be that failure for the child that
causes them to embark on their own uh
Journey in life to solve that problem
but I I do believe that there's some um
maybe not pain but that there's some uh
story that that child has told
themselves about themselves that they
are trying to
reconcile now you bring up one
interesting point with this question and
that
is is what happens in human psychology
always going to be applicable in in
stories of speculative
fiction many times uh we create
characters that are just pure evil and
there's no um backstory or anything else
in our story that leads to that and I
think that can be okay but I think we
have to recognize what we're doing is
creating a character that is in service
to a larger idea that trying to express
and so if that character is going to
have these um uh very evil ways or
Tendencies um and there's no pain
connected to it well then I think we
have to see what are we trying to
express thematically in this story what
what are we trying to say is true about
the world in this story and if that
serves that larger theme about what
we're saying is true in the world then I
think it can work but I think it can be
a way of identifying oh perhaps I'm
expressing something in this story that
is thematically not what I really
believe and could also be an
otherworldly uh you know some some type
of demonic entity that that there's no
full explanation of why they're acting
this way the story and and I think that
you talked about having a character
that's so bad that we just we can't look
at it I think for some of us that we're
willing to suspend disbelief or whatever
it is when it's a when it's an
otherworldly character because it's not
human well and I think it also goes back
to the whole uh asop approach of if I
look at all the characters in that story
as being different aspects of my own
self then yeah I can say sometimes there
there's this part of me that just wants
to push the books off the table and be
terrible you know um so I I can see
those characters also being an
expression of something that's inside of
me